now that i've learned what actually like  it means to gaslight because i didn't  really understand it up until like i  don't know [ __ ] three weeks ago i  think it's the funniest thing ever  just  finally figured it out  just  just making people believe [ __ ] no no  that's not it was it is it jazz light  oh that's right pronouncing it all  [ __ ] up it's like jelena oh like that  have either of you ever caught yourself  potentially gaslighting in an argument  sure yeah and then i'm like you know  what let me stop myself right there yeah  speak the truth  [Laughter]  i just read it more like sometimes lena  and i'll get like some stupid argument  and then i'll say i did something with a  lot of confidence and then i'll have a  second later where i go did i do that  and then i'm like  and i have to double down yeah i think  gaslighting is just an accident yeah  really yeah exactly yeah uh gaslighted a  uh a famous nfl quarterback  enough yeah no that was gaslighting